all right Zach so my problem I feel like
you can relate to a little um facial
here mm-hmm yeah totally so next to
someone and she eats the same salad
every day and the salad dressing is so
smelly
I understand it's healthy for you but I
can't deal with it
I sit across from someone and we share a
footrest underneath our desk and they
take up the whole footrest but not only
that but their feet goes way past it and
so sometimes it hits my legs my boss's
birthday's coming up and I'm curious
what is an appropriate gift it's been a
BuzzFeed for a year and a half now um
and there's a co-worker of mine who's
been spelling my name wrong the entire
time you know what kind of salad
dressing it is is it ranch
it's a raspberry vinaigrette tell them
in the store one of the worst kale yeah
raspberry vinaigrette kale three words
I've never liked it's strange that you
share a footrest with someone I mean
what's the footrest budget at uh at
BuzzFeed do you know I'm not sure about
that does he have tattoos no tattoos
that I've seen I've never seen him naked
I don't know what he looks like
do you think maybe if you ask him to see
him naked or he his birthday that would
be a gift for him yeah hey can I see you
naked for your for your birthday
how do you spell it Li NDS a why they
spell it ey ah this is tough because
what the thing is is that Lindsey or
excuse me Lindsey I don't like her
eating at her desk I don't I don't think
that that's I think that's rude I think
that's where that's the advice I'm gonna
give you is tell her to eat in her car
my sister's feet smell like Doritos and
I think if you could maybe get a good
Dorito sweat going yeah take your shoes
off maybe wait make it wear some wool
socks and
then get a good foot sweat prop your
feet up that lady and gonna get a free
clothes jersey up just be honest with
them say I got you this gift certificate
to Souplantation
I'm assuming that's an expensive gift
it's a hot spot I did it because I need
you to promote me I'll tell you a true
story I propose this a little bit my
brother his name is Greg okay and five
years ago I just called my sister me and
I'm like Mia let's start calling Greg
Craig for no reason for five years we've
called him Craig text of hey Craig are
you going home for Thanksgiving
he's never said anything about it he's
winning so if you don't let things get
to you okay and if you actually change
your name to the correct spelling let's
be honest
wait a minute let's be honest you think
it's Lindsay Lohan smells her a why and
if Lindsay does it it's right how many
followers does she have now hi a couple
mil you mind if I please
I got it in junior high like 13 years
ago we'll be right back with the world's
worst bragger ha ha